the cape fear river runs down the
eastern half of north carolina
passing by major cities before emptying
into the atlantic ocean
right here at the bottom of the river
basin is wilmington
a city known for its iconic riverwalk
that's where you'll find
this sign describing the importance of
this river to the region
it flows southeast for 200 miles has the
largest basin in the state covering more
than 9 000 square miles
and drainage from four cities and runoff
from factories farms and home sites in
29 counties
flows into it this river system provides
water to the entire basin
and the cape fear is one of wilmington's
main sources of drinking water
a nationwide test of tap water recently
ranked both wilmington
and neighboring brunswick county in the
top five for high levels
of pfas contamination a group of
chemicals found in many
everyday products anything that is water
repellent and it's stain resistance in
it
fire retardant popcorn bags and dental
floss and
pizza boxes rain gear and sleeping bags
food containers and makeup it's
everywhere
tracing the sources of chemicals in this
north carolina river
tells you exactly how the water got so
contaminated
and it also tells you how chemical
companies are getting away with
polluting our drinking water
not just here but throughout the united
states
this happens to be ground zero
for these chemicals being discharged
into the water in the air
99 percent of all americans have this in
their blood
[Music]
yet another chemical compound found in
the river chemicals used in consumer
products like
fire fighting foam and non-stick
products could lead
to cancer prompting concerns about the
drinking water in southeastern north
carolina
it has a lot of different names but it's
basically
what they call forever chemicals they're
long chained floral carbons
designed to withstand
any kind of breakdown
forever chemicals or pfas have strong
molecular bonds that repel
oil water and stains and can withstand
extreme heat making them
almost indestructible it was actually
invented to
coat tanks and military instruments
to protect it from the elements chemical
companies like dupont have been making
pfas since the 1930s
all around us are the products of modern
chemistry
even burned food won't stick to teflon
choose a dupont nonstick there's nothing
like
dupont now there are nearly 5 000
different forever chemicals and pfas is
an umbrella term for all of them
one of them pifoa was used by dupont to
make teflon
also known as c8 it was the subject of a
2001 class
action lawsuit claiming dupont
contaminated drinking water in
ohio and west virginia pfas chemicals
accumulate in our bodies
and that buildup can cause health
problems long afterwards
you can't see it you can't taste it the
kinds of impacts that
occur with it takes some time to develop
as a result of the lawsuit dupont funded
a science panel that
in 2012 found probable links between c8
exposure and health problems like cancer
after testing almost 70 000 people in
the area
five years later dupont settled without
admitting any wrongdoing
despite evidence that they had known for
decades about the harmful effects of
pfas
they had also agreed to stop making ca
but by then
pfast contamination had cropped up
elsewhere
the cape fear river basin begins here
near the city of greensboro
in water samples taken from lakes in the
area researchers found a forever
chemical called
phos it was coming from here the
piedmont triad international airport
pfas is in the firefighting foam used
during training exercises conducted at
airports like this one here and that
runoff
flows into the upper river basin farther
down
on the ha river a tributary of the cape
fear
forever chemicals are coming from a
different source
[Music]
the people that do know about it they
don't drink the water
there's people considering leaving
because they don't feel like their water
is safe
emily sutton is a conservationist who
tests the ha river for contamination
this spot in the hall is directly
impacted by the pfas load that's coming
directly from burlington's east
wastewater treatment plant
it's about 300 yards upstream
the filters at the treatment facility
are not designed to remove pfas
so wastewater coming from nearby
industries arrives and leaves containing
similar levels of pfas contamination
their effluent from the wastewater
treatment plant comes directly into the
haw
and we know that city of burlington's
wastewater treatment plant
is the main source for pfas but
they're not necessarily creating the
pfas it's
all of these different industries that
are sending their waste
to that wastewater treatment plant a few
miles down river
a water sample taken from beneath a
bridge crossing the ha
showed high levels of pfas and as the
river
flows down towards wilmington chemicals
from other sources accumulate
and push pfast levels even higher near
the city
but it's not just the levels that start
to change
if you look at the kinds of pfas in that
sample you'll notice something else in
the water
a newer type of forever chemical called
gen x
it came from here at the camour's
chemical plant located between the two
sample sites
the plant released wastewater into the
cape fear river containing gen x
and also emitted the chemical into the
air where it settles on nearby land
and entered the river as runoff 70 miles
downstream
an intake pipe pulls in river water and
supplies it to wilmington
the discovery of gen x and wilmington's
drinking water was front page news in
2017.
when we woke up and saw the star news
article that gen x was in our water
a group of citizens we all got together
around a dining room table and
and realized that we needed to address
this head-on
two years later emily donovan submitted
water samples from wilmington
and brunswick county to a nationwide
study measuring pfas levels in tap water
her brunswick county sample came from
belleville elementary school
i went back to my kids school because i
was curious to see what they were still
drinking
that sample was the highest reported in
that study
and it was devastating i mean nobody
wants to be the top of that list
i think back now to maybe what we
might have accidentally been exposed to
why we were
on the banks of the cape fair river
letting our kids play i mean i've got
photos and i go back and look at them
and i'm thinking to myself what were we
waiting in
millions of people depend on the cape
fear river basin for their water
but throughout the country other
americans are drinking forever chemicals
what you think is happening in north
carolina is staying there
it's just not the case it's it's
everywhere
communities in michigan new york
california pennsylvania and elsewhere
have discovered pfas in their drinking
water
this map shows pfas contamination across
the u.s
and many communities have yet to be
tested
the answer here is not to put the burden
of safety on
the homeowner on the consumer you have
to stop
these pollutants at the source the real
problem
is at the regulatory level in america
it falls to us the ordinary people to
prove that these chemicals are toxic
before the chemical is regulated by our
government
that is simply backwards there's
something that's called the
precautionary principle
we don't really apply it here in the
united states but what it says
is before you can bring a chemical to
the market you've got to prove
that that chemical is safe for the
consumer we have the inverse of that
i've been arguing for some time about
our country and
our state adopting a proprietary
principle which means don't
put anything in air or water that you
think is not safe
right now companies can sell products
without declaring all the chemicals they
contain
even if they're harmful for consumers so
we're left with
tens of thousands of chemicals on the
market that we have no
idea whether they are safe for
consumption or not
but with a precautionary principle in
place the government adds a preventative
check by requiring companies to prove
the safety of the chemicals
in their products before they reach
consumers if i knew
that i could potentially get cancer by
having stain resistant carpet
then i would make a better decision for
myself but i'm not even given that
choice right now
and knowing which chemicals are toxic
would allow the government to look for
those contaminants in the air and water
while also requiring companies to filter
chemicals out of their wastewater
north carolina is the perfect example
where there's nothing
when we don't have any information we
don't know how to assess them and
address them so they don't get talked
about
without a precautionary principle
chemicals like gen x can go unchecked
and even when companies get caught for
one toxic chemical
they can replace it with another when
dupont agreed to stop making the teflon
pfas c8 by 2015
ca blood levels dropped for the average
american but in the meantime dupont
introduced a new chemical in 2009 to
replace c8
and in 2015 spun off a new company
camours
to produce it in north carolina that new
chemical
was gen x
it's just this game of whack-a-mole that
one gets regulated and you have a new
one pop
up as forever chemicals become a
nationwide conversation
some states are starting to respond
washington state
san francisco and maine have banned pfas
in food packaging
and many states have proposed
prohibiting firefighting foam containing
pfas
including north carolina but a larger
effort to eliminate pfast chemicals
is still pending there is still no legal
requirement to filter pfas
from tap water so more than 100 million
americans today
are likely drinking water contaminated
with pfas
i think protecting public water and the
public health isn't really controversial
but how we get there is
you know industry's got a lot at stake
here so
it stays out there forever and it
accumulates in us so
we all have a we all have a stake in
this
[Music]
you